I was declared unfit by the occupational physician
what will happen
professional incapacity
is the fact of not being fit anymore
to take up your current job
often unfitness is declared
following a work stoppage
or an accident at work
professional unfitness is mandatory
established
by the occupational physician and not by the
handler he can declare you unfit
partially or totally
but before declaring unfit
it has four steps to follow
conduct a medical examination
after conducting a workstation study
conduct a study of working conditions
in the company
and exchange with the employer to find out
some comments from his employer
and talk to him about a possibility of changing his position
of the employee
now if the occupational physician declares you unfit
he must write a notice of incapacity and give it to you
as soon as the occupational physician declares you unfit
the employer
must be aware of this notice of unfitness
and must reclassify you in another job that is
adequate in the life of incapacity
it can be indicated
that the morning of the job can be dangerous for you
or that your state of
health does not allow you to be reclassified
in this case
the employer does not have to reclassify you
now if you
refuse the job he offers you for the reclassification
or that the employer cannot reclassify you
with supporting justification
and that there are the two mentions I'm talking about on
the life of incapacity
you are dismissed for professional unfitness